Now, it's time for America to bind the wounds of division, have to get together.
To all Republicans and Democrats and independents across this nation,...
...I say it is time for us to come together as one united people.
It's time.
I pledge to every citizen of our land that I will be President for all Americans...
...and this is so important to me.
For those who have chosen not to support me in the past,...
...of which there were a few people,...
...I'm reaching out to you for your guidance and your help...
...so that we can work together and unify our great country.
As I've said from the beginning, ours was not a campaign...
...but rather an incredible and great movement,...
...made up of millions of hardworking men and women who love their country...
...and want a better, brighter future for themselves and for their family.
It's a movement comprised of Americans from all races,...
...religions, backgrounds and beliefs,...
...who want and expect our government to serve the people...
...and serve the people, it will.
Working together, we will begin the urgent task of rebuilding our nation...
...and renewing the "American Dream".
I've spent my entire life in business,...
...looking at the untapped potential in projects and in people all over the world.
That is now what I want to do for our country.